at 8 30 a.m in Midtown Manhattan a man
was seen hanging out the window on the
31st floor of a luxury high-rise this
video is crazy according to law
enforcement officials the FBI was
attempting to serve the man with an
arrest warrant for felony fraud and
grand larceny that's when he broke
through the apartment Window and
threatened to jump after nearly eight
hours the standoff finally ended when an
NYPD emergency service unit officer look
at this repelled off the side of the
building outside of the 72-story
skyscraper and brought the man inside he
was then taken into custody at this time
it's unclear what federal charges he
will face but shout out to those police
officers uh the man is undergoing
psychiatric evaluation